Wenn sich Sarah Gierig an die Arbeit macht,
wird aus Schokolade Kunst
– ob die Skulptur eines Kraken oder
ein bunt bepinselter Clown.
Ihre Kreativität setzt sie auch ein,
wenn sie Schokoladenfiguren
für die Weihnachtszeit entwirft.
Ja, und natürlich hier für Kinder:
das Paradies ohne Ende.
Im Schnee spielen die Pinguine mit ’m Elch.
Also, ich finde, zu Weihnachten muss
immer das Gesamtpaket stimmen.
Also, das soll schmecken, es soll
schön aussehen und ...
also, ich will einfach die Menschen
glücklich machen und
denen ein Lächeln ins Gesicht zaubern.
Und momentan ist halt so der Trend
auch ’n bissel, dass alles schön bunt ist
und knallig, dass man ...
Das nennt sich „mood food“.
Dass man glücklich ist
vom bloßen Hinschauen.
In Schokolade stecken unzählige Aromen.
Die herauszuschmecken,
ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Sarah Gierig beherrscht sie,
denn die gelernte Konditorin
ist auch Schokoladen-Sommelière
– eine Expertin für das süße Genussmittel.
Ihre Kreationen präsentiert sie im Geschäft
ihrer Eltern im sächsischen Neustadt.
Eine gute Schokolade erkennt man
an dem wunderschönen Glanz,
an dem knackigen Bruch.
Die muss richtig schön knacken,
und beim Verkosten ist es ganz wichtig,
dass man die Schokolade 30 Sekunden
im Mund behält, weil dann schmilzt erst
die Kakaobutter und die ganzen leckeren
Geschmacksaromen können sich bilden.
Wir testen das mal.
Am Anfang steht die Kakaobohne,
die nur in der Nähe des Äquators wächst.
Sie wird geröstet und
zu Rohschokolade verarbeitet, die
– je nachdem, wo sie herkommt –
immer anders schmeckt.
Natürlich muss ich auch immer
wieder meine Sinne schulen.
Also, man sollte das wirklich trainieren.
Ich denke, die ganzen Weinsommeliers,
die machen das auch ganz oft.
Wenn zum Beispiel Zusatzstoffe einen zu
niedrigen Kakaogehalt der Schokolade
verschleiern sollen,
schmeckt Sarah Gierig das sofort.
Die Schokolade schmeckt
so ’n bisschen fruchtig und säuerlich.
Also, ich tippe auf Afrika und würde sagen:
Die hat auch so um die 60, 70 Prozent,
also so 65 Prozent.
Also tippe ich auf Madagaskar.
Die afrikanische Kakaobohne ist
auch eine gute Grundlage
für Schokoladenspezialitäten
in der Weihnachtszeit.
Besonders beliebt sind traditionelle Motive
und klassische Geschmacksrichtungen.
Zwar engen die Klischees
des christlichen Festes
Sarah Gierigs Kreativität
manchmal etwas ein …
... aber man kann immer wieder
was Neues erfinden.
Jetzt ist ja der neue Trend „foodpairing“.
Das heißt, Geschmacksaromen,
die gut miteinander kombinierbar sind,
verbindet man. Zum Beispiel machen
wir jetzt was ganz Verrücktes:
Also, ich hab jetzt hier ’n Orangenöl,
und da braten wir jetzt Speck an
und verbinden das dann mit Sahne
und dunkler Schokolade
und machen mal ’ne ganz crazy Praline.
Der Sud aus Speck, Sahne‚ Dill
und geraspelten Orangenschalen
wird durch ein Sieb passiert
und mit Schokolade verrührt.
Fertig ist die Füllung einer
extravaganten Schokoladenpraline.
Doch egal ob Sarah Gierig
schräge oder konventionelle
Weihnachtsdelikatessen kreiert
– die wichtigste Zutat für sie:
Mein absolutes Geheimrezept ist: immer mit
ganz viel Liebe machen. Und alles ...
es muss alles von Herzen kommen
und es muss Spaß und Freude machen.
Und das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste
überhaupt bei meinem Beruf,
weil ... wenn es mir keinen Spaß
mehr macht, dann schmeckt man das auch.
Und mit solchen Schokoladenvariationen
wird Weihnachten auf jeden Fall
ein buntes Fest für alle Sinne.